i just got to say man do you have a  full-time psychiatrist on staff dealing  with all the stuff you have to deal with  in brooklyn  [Laughter]  what i got to deal with i'm making  millions of dollars playing back i know  that but you got to deal with the james  situation you don't deal with that  anymore you got kyrie going on i mean  it's always drama around that team so i  know you got to have somebody to talk to  because it's hectic  i love my brothers regardless  you know i just got to say man do you  have a full-time psychiatrist on staff  dealing with all the stuff you have to  deal with in brooklyn  [Laughter]  what i got to deal with i'm making  millions of dollars playing basketball i  know that but you got to deal with the  james situation you don't deal with that  anymore you got kyrie going on i mean  it's always drama around that team so i  know you got to have somebody to talk to  because it's hectic  i love my brothers regardless  you know